hey guys it's been a while I'm sorry for
the weight and the lack of updates this
year has been hectic for me so far and
unfortunately it's still really intense
but I figured I'm always gonna be busy
and I want to make time for this firstly
thank you so much for all the comments
on my last video it was overwhelming
they were so kind and there were so many
suggestions that I want to try out but
for now I'm not going to I don't have
the time to do that properly till I
graduate in early December instead I'm
gonna start slow for example one thing I
really want to do with my videos is tap
into my biggest resource you guys this
community honestly the fact that you're
watching videos about quantum mechanics
in your spare time pretty much
guarantees you're awesome
I want these videos to be more of a
two-way thing and ideally I'd love it if
you guys talked to each other with that
aim in mind I'm gonna upload a video
this week that's a puzzle that I hope
you'll attempt but before that why don't
you tell me a bit about yourself and why
you're interested in learning online
I've gotten to know some of you already
and loved it you seem to come from such
diverse backgrounds and I'd really enjoy
hearing from more of you if you want to
leave a comment here please make sure
that you have a Google+ account or I
can't actually reply to that comment
otherwise you could leave a comment on
any of these sites I think as for the
plans with the videos I can't get back
into serious video making until I
graduate in two months so I won't be
doing full quantum videos until then but
in the meantime I was hoping to tell you
about my research in quantum computers
and make some smaller easier videos I'll
aim for about two a month and hopefully
I don't regret saying that when I'm
writing up my thesis this year has been
amazing for me I've gotten to know whole
areas of physics I hardly knew about
previously gotten a lot more practical
teaching experience from lab
demonstrating for undergraduates and by
giving several talks this year on my
research project and mostly from forcing
all my friends to listen to me rant
about it as the quantum mechanics I have
learnt a lot and I can't wait to teach
it to you properly anyway
thank you for being understanding and
putting up with me through this long
wait remember to tell me about yourself
and I will see you a bit later this week